all right everybody start to shut up
let's go ahead and wrap up your current
sentences and get yourselves to a quiet
place mr. Griffin dan is in my seat okay
I didn't even know was his you added me
to this weird class and now I don't know
what's going on calm down calm down
let's let's don't be so rule minded no
point in your adult lives will you ever
have assigned seats besides airplanes
and jury duty
if I've already undercut myself don't
add to it okay as you all know this week
we are devoting our attention to the
psychological dismantling of my academic
rival miles leonard miles happens to be
british he also happens to be adopted so
this week we will practice and perfect
British accents and who was ever his
best we'll call him posing as his
biological birth mother who he's never
met and tell him some sort of
devastating secret
[Music]
any questions mr. Griffin are you
seriously never gonna teach us biology
at all sure Sarita maybe Pablo Picasso
can come in and teach driver's ed guys I
am a published Harvard philosophy
professor I have no interest whatsoever
in teaching biology to you people okay
so drop it that's a pretty sweet deal on
the table play ball get an A well let's
make this easy I'm just I'm just trying
to cope through a year in Toledo with
its miserable excuse for espresso put
your hand down next words I hear out of
you better be in a British accent the
bookstore at the mall has good
expresso milord hey not bad
looks like Anthony's out to an early
lead nice let's open it up yeah remember
British female hurtful go okay what is
this class
you